bonjour et bienvenue avec nous sur rt
france à leur isolement de sept jours
désormais si on est positif et
complètement vaccinés pas de quarantaine
pour les cas contactez également s'ils
sont totalement vacciner que pensez vous
de ces nouvelles mesures
je pense que ces mesures sont logiques
omicron arrive en 3 jours donc une
incubation plus courte que les variants
précédent
très atténué chez les personnes qui sont
complètement vaccinés avant tout avec
trois doses et pourrait partir plus
rapidement ce qui re en plus des raisons
économiques pourraient justifier
effectivement des mesures d'isolement
allégé par rapport à ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à présent alors omicron delta qui
est vraiment responsable de l'actuelle
flambée épidémique c'est vrai que c'est
un peu flou pour le moment
en france c'est flou parce que comme moi
à santé publique france et mister
mystère de la santé ont été plus capable
jusqu'à présent de nous donner des
chiffres fiables
crédibles
un peu partout en france et puis en
montrant l'évolution
on ne sait vraiment pas
quelle est la proportion réelle 2
microns par rapport à delta on a
l'impression quand même parce qu'il ya
quand même des types âge qui sont faits
dans les hôpitaux que en réanimation
c'est surtout des deltas ayant
particulièrement dans le sud de la
france mais tout ça reste un peu flou
qui complique la compréhension de cette
vague et puis les mesures de grande
mental bien entendu pour l'instant est
ce qu'on peut dire qu mikron est
manifestement moins dangereux que delta
toutes les données qu'on a il rase pas
de france puisque on n'a pas du tout
mais d'afrique du sud d'angleterre qui à
peu près quinze jours trois semaines
d'avancé par rapport à nous du danemark
montrent effectivement une sévérité plus
faible de mikron particulièrement chez
les personnes vaccinées et donc on voit
bien l'angleterre où il ya une
augmentation
modérée
du nombre de personnes hospitalisées
surfe à londres où beaucoup de gens sont
pas vaccinés mais pas véritablement
d'augmentation en réa et un mentation de
la mortalité ce qui démontre bien dans
un pays où beaucoup de gens ont eu trois
doses que micron devra être moins sévère
que les verrières possédant par vous
parler de l'afrique du sud en afrique du
sud justement qui a affirmé ya quelques
jours avoir dépassé le pic de la vague
omicron y avoir connu des
hospitalisations en diminution par
rapport aux vagues précédent qu'est ce
que ça peut vouloir dire pour nous
européens
ce que ça peut vouloir dire en se
méfiant quand même que les chaque pays
est différent que c'est une population
jeune dont l'afrique du sud qui avait
été très fortement touchés par les
vagues précédentes mais ça peut vouloir
dire effectivement que dans une
quinzaine de jours
peut-être un peu plus on aura été au pic
de la vaccination je pars dans nos pics
de l'infection par omicron et avec les
vaccinations qui aux demandes il va y
avoir une baisse tout aussi rapide qu'on
a eu en afrique du sud c'est vrai qu'il
est gay heureusement dans l'espère
beaucoup de morts et de gens en
réanimation
alors la vaccination des enfants c'est
un que le gouvernement font ces avancées
plutôt prudemment sur les questions il a
désormais établir un calendrier en la
vaccination des enfants est possible
mais elle est facultative
pensez vous qu'elle soit nécessaire pour
endiguer la chaîne de contamination
le seul bémol que je vois aujourd'hui
sur un micro ondes c'est qu'il ya des
publications des rapports qui disent que
chez l'enfant en mikron par contre pour
être plus grave que le delta est
d'ailleurs il ya quand même beaucoup
d'enfants
notamment en angleterre aux etats-unis
voire en france qui sont hospitalisés
heureusement il noir très rarement mais
quand même hospitalisé par infection
donc ne faut pas vraiment dire que c'est
totalement ménage chez l'enfant cela dit
ça n'est le plus souvent la vraie
question c'est est ce que à partir des
enfants on va voir les personnes âgées
rappelons quand même qu'en france il ya
cinq millions de personnes qui seront
pas vaccinés et beaucoup de gens âgés
qu'on paye la troisième dose est ce que
ces enfants vont passer la maladie les
gens qui vont faire une forme sévère
parce qu'ils n'auront pas le schéma
vaccinal complet ça c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser
philippe froguel vous êtes chercheur et
généticiens merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage